And here is my answer, to return the probability of heads given a set of probabilities of heads
and a set of probabilities for each coin, we just need to add up the probability
of head for each coin multiplied by the probability it could be that coin.
To do that, I will just use this nifty little Python feature
that let's me walk through these lists together called zip.
We'll just take two lists and gives me the first two items, then the next two items, then next two items
and so on and I call the probability of a coin coming up heads p coin
and the probability of it being that coin p.
And so we just need to multiply those two things together and Python has a nice little sum functions
which sums up the whole thing and we will just return that.
Now the slightly trickier bit is this update piece.
First to make my life easier, I'll just store the current value of the probability of heads.
We need this because if you recall the denominator of Bayes' Rule is the probability of the result.
Now if the result is heads, we want to update our probabilities using the
same basic method of walking through these two lists together.
We're going to update this by taking the probability for the given coin and
multiplying it by the probability that we would have gotten that result that is p coin
which is just the entry from coins which is the probability of heads for that coin
and since we'd got heads that is the probability of the result given that it's the coin
and we just divide it by the total probability of it being heads
and if it's tails, we just need to do the reverse.
The probability of having tails given that it's a certain coin
is just going to be 1 minus the probability with being heads.
Again, we have to multiply it by the probability that it's that coin in the first place
and then we again just divide by the total probability of it being tails which is just
one minus the probability of being heads.